hey guys Pete here once again we made it
to Saturday and there's some news to
talk about and spoilers coming out of
the season 7 filming for Game of Thrones
this will be my weekly spoiler report
and it will contain spoilers for
everything that's going on related to
season 7 if you're not a fan of having
things spoiled that might come up in the
next season then you're gonna want to
stop watching now make sure you check
out one of my non-spoiler videos from
this week though because I'm having a
book giveaway and I want you to enter
everyone else can stick around to the
end to learn more about that and with
the spoiler warning out of the way let's
jump into it so overall this was a
pretty slow weekend it was kind of
surprising since we had so much coming
out of the set from the battle scene
last week in contrast this week there's
been pretty much no new footage that
I've seen except for a pretty big shot
we get to look at at the end of this
video so no new shots of the the big
ambush but I guess we'll see some more
of that maybe next week first thing we
heard this week was that the Game of
Thrones show would be returning to
Croatia where they shot the King's
Landing scenes for so many years this
isn't very exciting other than you know
it might bring us a shot of something
that we've seen in the past that they
didn't want to shoot in Spain last year
they said the same thing they wouldn't
be shooting there and then they ended up
shooting the scene where Jamie brought
Marcella home and you know it was on
that beach that we had seen before so
there's some speculation here but I
don't really know without any more
details what we can expect that they're
shooting there but apparently they're
getting extras in there shooting over a
two-day period on Sunday night Twitter
started going crazy because they dropped
a little mini glimpse at season seven on
the pre-roll ad for coming in 2017 on
HBO before Westworld so a lot of people
were talking about it and I thought
maybe there was a little bit more to it
but it's really just three quick images
of Sansa Arya and Jon Snow it's still
pretty awesome to see Arya especially on
the horse looking like a northern man
it looks like there's snow behind her so
she's in the north but really it was
kind of underwhelming once we got a look
at the actual video since it was such a
short clip not sure that this really
brings up any new information that we
haven't already been talking about in
the spoiler videos so let's hope we get
an extended version of this in the near
future some casting news came out and it
could be pretty interesting as related
to arias storyline the first actor in
particular Brendon Morrissey is said to
be brought on to play a phrase Lord in
one of the Jeremy Podesta
directed episodes we know that he
directed episode 1 and the season finale
so it's likely he'll be there in the
aftermath of what aria did at the twins
in episode 10 of season 6
we know she knocked off Walter while she
was in the middle of feeding him Lothar
and black Walder something that's been
on my mind was if we were going to see
any more of the phrase after that point
knowing that in the books you know
Walter old Walter the original Walder
Frey was like 92 or 93 and had offspring
all over the place the show version
though you know never really mentioned a
lot of the different sons and grandsons
and different things that he had so it
seemed like that could be a quick scene
to end them off but with this guy
popping up it looks like we'll probably
get another Frey Aria confrontation
before she moves away from the
Riverlands leaked Watchers will point
out that there was some mention of this
that she might wipe them all out so that
could be a definite possibility either
way it's kind of interesting and it
would be nice to see the the phrase and
how things end up before Aria moves on
we don't know anything really about the
second actor other than he you know his
agency said that he had a nice
supporting role and that he was in Spain
so he could be basically anyone and I
just really don't know if you guys have
any guesses make sure you leave him in
the comments sophie turner did an
interview with Entertainment Weekly
about what we could expect for salsa as
far as a turn in season 7 of course we
saw her at the end of season 6 in a
pretty good position but there was that
strange look between her and
Littlefinger which made it unclear about
how she felt about John being
King in the North when the Astor she
said she that's on two seemingly in
control for the first time and it really
suits her she's kind of having a bit of
a power trip but she's also becoming
more insecure because there are threats
to the power that she holds so this
could obviously tie into what we've
talked about in past boiler videos in
relation to Littlefinger and his
scheming Turner went on to say what
overall excites me about this season is
that the main characters are coming
together and it feels like things are
ramping up it's really exciting it all
feels like it's coming to a big
conclusion so that's exciting in that we
know that some of the Starks siblings
are probably going to be back at
Winterfell I'm talking about REM bran of
course so this seems to kind of back
that up Alfie Allen who plays Theon
Greyjoy also had an interview and
whenever he was asked he said it will be
more the same but better more dragons
more torture that makes me worried I
hope it's not Theon's torture that we're
talking about here we've talked about
Fiona and his story for season seven in
a couple of the older spoiler videos so
you might want to go back and watch
those but if you've been following along
since I started making these you know
that you know he's probably going to do
something that's gonna get him in
trouble with the Ironborn whenever asked
about how his current emotional state
was Alan described Theon as skittish and
full of fear basically and then that can
kind of I guess evolve into rage which
you might see who knows he was also
asked about how Theon will feel when he
sees Jon Snow or Sansa again by the you
know the audience that was at this fan
convention he was answering questions at
he corrected them by saying you mean if
that happens and saying gotta stop
looking at the internet guys he did go
on to answer the question as though it
were hypothetical I would say Theon
would feel horrible he'd feel awful and
he'd see it as a chance to redeem
himself this is kind of where I think
his story's going I which I mentioned
when we talked about that scene in the
past video so that's not a big surprise
to me the mountain was also interviewed
where he dropped something that is
pretty innocuous
in my opinion but a lot of people got
going and thinking about some hype so
I'll talk about the
right now when the mountain talk to
express he said that he could see that
him and his brother might clash he
didn't know for sure basically he said
he could see it happening in the future
because it looks like it would go that
way because if you look at the story it
looks like that well that's not really
confirming anything as far as I'm
concerned you know I mean it's just sort
of a thing we know that those two are in
the same place you know that from my
older spoiler video about the big King's
Landing scene at the dragon pit that
we're gonna see but we also know from
that that we didn't hear any report of
them filming a scene like that so clam
Bowl fans really got excited saying that
that he was basically letting it slip
but I don't really see that is the case
that you know it's up to you guys what
you think but in my opinion he basically
said he didn't know if they would get
into it and I'd take him at his word
beyond that it was a quiet week up until
the end
we got a drone some drone footage of the
Wolfe quarry site which is pretty cool
but we already had photos of that that
showed it in more detail it's kind of
interesting though the videos out there
you can go and watch it it's like seven
minutes long of the drone flying around
the scene you can't make out any actors
or anything like that though we also got
a bunch of photos from the kisara a set
where they're getting ready to shoot
there are nice photos of the you know
the location but there's nothing in
there to give away what they might be or
you know what they might be shooting
there so we're just gonna have to wait
and see until those take off then at the
eleventh hour a really big leaked scene
popped up and you know it's by far the
biggest news that we had this week
last night I was shuffling through
Twitter and I saw a winner is coming had
posted that there was a leaked scene so
I checked out their site and they
usually get scooped by Watchers on the
wall on some of the other ones but this
was the first I've heard of this so I
have to give him credit for bringing
this out in the middle of the night in
the u.s. so the scene was a forty second
scene that's been released on YouTube
that's directly on the set of season
seven but it's hard to tell what exactly
is going on other than someone obviously
gets fireballed by a dragon so the scene
was at night you can clearly see that
there's you know safety text there and
they're setting up for this scene and we
have a cloaked figure
whose heads covered which may be related
to the fact that you know he's in his
stunt gear more than it being indicative
of the fact that the character who's
being burnt would it be wearing some
kind of a cloak or hood according to
people who are able to make out the
audio the actor says no Khaleesi what
foul witchcraft is this now when you
watch the video there's a commentator
speaking over top that speaks only in
Spanish so I don't know what he's saying
other people are saying that while
speaking Spanish he says clearly James
Faulkner's name which is something that
we've heard that's gonna happen because
he plays randyll Tarly but I can't say
from the actual footage that this is
something that we can look and say hey
look that is definitely entirely right
there and if it is Tarly why would he
call her Khaleesi I mean I know it's one
of her names but it's an eastern word
and it's directly related to the
Dothraki which if we know how Tarly is
he's not liking anybody who's not
Westerosi so that seems a little off to
me maybe some of you guys who speak
Spanish can you know glean more from the
actual recording based on what the
commentators saying but it's pretty
awesome to look at you know even if we
know that it's expected that some people
learning and burn by dragons I also
wonder because there's gonna be massive
amounts of CGI involved like for one
there's gonna be a dragon at it in there
you know we don't see anyone standing
next to the fireball but we wouldn't see
that in a in this kind of a scene they
wouldn't put someone who's a high-paid
act they're next to a volatile dangerous
situation so again what they say he says
as these were all around in the flames
there's no clue see what foul witchcraft
is this I hope you guys will help me out
with leaving comments about what you
think's happening there
it's definitely right for speculation so
let's see what you guys think that'll do
it for this week I hope next week we'll
have some more battle scenes to look
over in the meantime you know if you
haven't if you're new to these spoiler
videos that I put out and putting them
out once a week so you want to go back
and check out a lot of the older ones
some of the stuff we've learned leading
up to this that's you know kind of
pointing us in the right direction as
far as what's going on in these scenes I
have a complete playlist which I'll link
to at the end of here that goes back
week by week and you can watch them all
please like this video if you enjoyed it
and definitely
subscribe so you can become eligible for
my book giveaway that's gonna be
dropping pretty soon now based on the
number of subscribers and how it's
growing when I reach 28 thousand
subscribers I'll pick one comment from
one of the videos that's eligible and I
will send that lucky commenter a copy of
the latest 20th anniversary edition of a
game of Thrones it's a nice illustrated
edition and it's great for the
collection and all you have to do is be
a subscriber and leave a comment in any
video that I mention this giveaway I'll
leave a link to the book in the
description so you can check it out if
you haven't seen it yet and with that
that'll end this week's video so thanks
for watching I'll talk to you soon